doing that with you I've actually never
done that with another actor but I've
never played the same the same
role how have you felt so far working
with me mostly behind the yeah I mean
the most fun thing to do was on my days
off when I'd have the opportunity to
come watch you guys we still have not
worked together technically not really
no one wants to see Kurt Russell Wyatt
Russell comos thank God for God
we both get to work with Godzilla he
fails to hit his marks never
know but he can do with his mouth he's
incredible being in the business for as
long as you have still being the most
excited person on set it's fun for me to
see my dad be that person for other
people hell of a job coil how many
Fathers and Sons have that opportunity I
got that right I'm just really glad we
did it it was fun it was great I had a
ball with
you